Takes courage to be a leader
in facing decisions and challenges.
Granted us our skills.
It takes attitude to become a good leader
where we stand firm in our values and principles
at all times.
Together let us learn by experiencing a school.
With the right assistance,
give us the opportunity to help you
and the best way we know how.
Let us reach out.
Our intention is to serve not for the fame,
not for the title,
but the willingness for the betterment of all.
Because that's who we are.
With honesty, compassion, perseverance and humility.
Our team is called for solidarity.
We are here.
We are ready whenever you call.
We respond to any issues or concerns.
Let us be the one who's there for you.
Most may we open your eyes
to the vision and mission of this crew
as it is engraved as the missions that we are.
Let this be the one next to it.